foreign
[Music]
you know what's perfect about today
everything yep
all right how's the neighborhood watch
going let me see what's happening
nothing just pink lots and lots of
things I don't hate the pink kind of
dreamy do these people work how can they
afford all this all right boys we're off
to work don't get too much sun Good Luck
run in the world have fun in outer space
wow these people haven't figured out
yeah they can have their mansions and
Astronaut shops because we'll always
have pizza hey enough sitting around
let's Gear Up
[Music]
did you get that April did you film that
sorry am I supposed to film all the
stuff you do because a lot of it's dumb
[Music]
what you looking after what you looking
at
g'day fellas
that one seems cool bro Broski bro bro
abracadabra
[Music]
Turtles
Mondo quit hugging everybody
no exclusively movie theaters August 2nd
get your tickets now
[Music]
thank you